تكاد الطبابه في لبنان ان تصبح حكرا على
قله من الميسورين الاف المرضى الفقراء
اصبح ملجؤهم الوحيد مستشفيات حكوميه ترزح
تحت ثقل ازمه اقتصاديه ارهقت القطاع
الصحيه برمته تزايد الاقبال على
المستشفيات الحكوميه شبه المجانيه مع
اللجوء المستشفيات الخاصه الى تقاضي
فواتيرها بالدولار فتضاعفت نسبه ما
يعالجون على نفقه وزاره الصحه مع تخلي
اغلبيه اللبنانيين عن التامين الخاص
لارتفاع كلفته وترافق ذلك مع انخفاض قياسي
في ميزانيه وزاره الصحه خلال السنوات
الاخيره نتيجه شح الموارد الماليه
هذا قسم غسيل الكلى داخل اكبر المستشفيات
الحكوميه في بيروت تزايد الاقبال عليه في
الاونه الاخيره بنحو ثلاثه اضعاف لكن
المكان لم يعد يتسع لمزيد من المرضى
يخضع بلال هنا لثلاث جلسات اسبوعيا يفاقم
معاناته الصحيه والنفسيه قلقه من احتمال
توقف وزاره الصحه عن توفير التغطيه
الكامله لعلاجه
الخاصه وضع بلا شغل مدى الحياه يعني وهلا
بالرغم نحنا عم بموتونا نحن عم بنموت
ونزل القرار يعني يا جماعه اللي عم تغسلوا
كلها روحوا يصفوا المسؤولون عن المستشفيات
الحكوميه وضعها بالماساوي لاسيما مع هجره
عدد كبير من الاطباء والممرضين ما دفعها
الى خفض نسبه اشغال الاسره واعطاء
الاولويه للحالات المستعجله والاكثر حرجه
لانه ما بقى في عنا محل عنا يعني فل ومثل
ما حكيت انه ما فينا نشيل المريض ونحط
مريض محله
يلي عنا بكفونا ثلاثه شيفت 155 وقلت لك
انه عدد الاطباء الاقل وعدد النورسيز
الممرضات اقل وتقول المستشفيات الحكوميه
ان ابرز المشكلات تكمن في ان وزاره الصحه
تسدد لها الفواتير بالليره اللبنانيه
وبسعر صرف متدند للدولار بينما هي مضطره
لشراء كل مستلزماتها بالدولار وفق سعر
السوق الموازيه الامر الذي يلحق بها خسائر
كبيره
كاترين حنا الجزيره بيروت